feels like a little mysterious pretty
serious but cool you know it's like
there's a lot going on right here
[Applause]
[Music]
that is Florida Georgia line's brand-new
single simple out today
happy Friday welcome to certified
country I'm selfish lacy and I am so
excited to bring you part two of my FGL
exclusive this time I'm taking you
inside tribe Kelley with Brian Kelley
and his wife Brittany they invited me
out for the launch of their new denim
collection last month and y'all it was a
vibe
[Music]
tell us the origins story behind track
le the name came from the night before
our wedding Tyler and Haley dropped off
a tepee and so Brittney and I after the
wedding kind of had a really cool
ceremony burnt some sage and that kind
of became the logo but um the clothing
line specifically was kind of birth on
the road we've been on tour with me the
past couple years and we found ourselves
altering our clothes and and customizing
things and doing stuff for the band and
also trying to as much as we were
traveling whether it was a plane or a
you know a bus whatever we wanted to be
comfortable but this girl right here
she's the boss lady and I'm thankful to
be on the ride she's an amazing creative
as well as an amazing businesswoman and
she's the brains behind this thing yeah
I feel like we just wanted to make it
like a family brand and make it feel
like a family brand you know and I also
have Native American ancestry and my
lineage so the TV just it felt fitting
you want to show me around the store a
little bigger pieces absolutely a lot of
our displays are old antiques and we
also sell old clothing here too so as
you're walking through you'll probably
see it some of that old and new kind of
mixed together do you guys want to show
me some of the vintage stuff I ever
absolutely yeah
do you handpick all of these mm-hmm yeah
me and Brittany together will go hey
babe doing a little t-shirt pick and
date we always pick whatever we feel is
like we're connected to whether that's
an old logging shirt or a an old vintage
Hawaii shirt or Puerto Rico travel
lately yeah we got you know old vintage
San Diego old Florida I mean look at
that but it's crusty it's all beautiful
beautiful you can't it'll make a look
you can try to make them like that but
you can't but you can find them at the
Trading Post once we decided to do the
denim line I said babe that's a good
thing because I know my show outfit here
on out to London I'm gone it's gonna be
double denim in some source so it's cool
that we get to wear our own and I like
how I show off the tattoo
and feeling feeling free on stage and I
don't know there's something about denim
that I I personally love the double
denim I think it pops on me Brittany do
you have a favorite pair of jeans that
you want to show me I do I have a
favorite pair of hurricanes a cashews ah
let's see the Dreamweavers so you have
these on these are your favorites
yes just because they're comfortable
it's hot waisted so it kind of locks you
in when you're on a plane I could wear
these they're not they don't pull at me
they're comfortable and they're just
free-flowing and kind of carefree so
just I love these now what are your
favorites Oh
show off in legs girl there's something
about the little color sub difference
right there I just think that is sexy
and we call me creatively fresh hadn't
seen things like that yeah they look
they look fire on you in their highways
didn't give you a good
these kind of giving me like I think the
way it's cut here giving me like
old-school Britney vibes
yes Mariah Carey Britney Spears back in
the day they both cut it directly off of
the ways and so we actually had these
manufactured this way and it's so funny
because we had the conversation with our
team and I'm trying to tell them I don't
want belt loops like I need you to cut
them in half and no one understands so
you got in there with so he got in there
and showed them exactly what we wanted
and we arranged the pockets in the back
and have this detail because this
actually gives you a butt lift and you
guys designed all of these right it's
good to get in there with them and
actually see exactly what goes into it
and and share our story with them down
to the buttons like the buttons on every
single pair of pants was actually
inspired by our wedding rings
these details are part of our story and
we want to let them in on it too I think
there's something to be said also about
a little bit extra thought and intention
you know to behind everything that we're
doing so like we've got you know a
little readout stash pocket that's her
handwriting so you know just going the
extra mile and adding details and yeah I
think every time you put on one of our
our pieces I think it will he'll learn
something new about it I wanted to talk
about your personal style and like what
kind of stuff you gravitate towards I
want to feel good in content but I also
want to be comfortable and be able to
sit and travel in my in my clothing
personally yeah I think being
comfortable feeling good you look good
you know and these jeans right here that
they're the tribe Kelly Beach man right
here and I love that as we were creating
them I wanted them to sit on my hip but
also be long enough okay you know and
then being able to perform them and move
that the the wash and the stretch allows
me to kind of move around but they still
they still fit right for everybody
clearly we had no fun at all but on a
serious note I want to mention that each
and every piece of tribe Kelly denim is
100% ethically produced and
american-made of course I couldn't leave
Nashville without a little piece of my
own Brian and Brittany were sweet enough
to give
with their traveller denim jacket
embroidered on site by Ranger stitch and
a few onesies for my little one on the
way
thank you so much guys Brian and I also
talked about FDLE's new music and he
told me that their fourth studio album
will be their best one yet so I am so
excited to hear more thank you for
watching I really hope you enjoyed our
special two-part exclusive if you did
miss last week's episode we visited with
Tyler Haley and little miss Olivia
Hubbard at home in Nashville as always
hit the comments let me know what you
thought of the show and be sure to
subscribe to entertainment tonight on
YouTube for more certified country we'll
have a new episode for you next Friday
[Music]